BRIAN KILMEADE.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
FBI STILL FRONT AND CENTER AS
NEW ALARMS ARE RAISED ON
CAPITOL HILL.
SENATE HOMELAND SECURITY CHAIR
RON JOHNSON HAS LEARNED OF AN
ANTI-TRUMP SECRET SOCIETY WITHIN
THE BUREAU ATTENDED BY TOP LEVEL
EMPLOYEES.
>> I HAVE HEARD FROM SOMEBODY
WAS TALK TO OUR COMMITTEE THAT
THERE IS A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
IN THE FBI THAT WERE HOLDING
SECRET OFF-SITE MEETINGS.
>> IS THAT HALF A DOZEN?
WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
>> I CAN'T REALLY PUT A NUMBER
THEY WERE VERY HIGH LEVEL WITHIN
THESE ARE NOT LOW-LEVEL
UNDERLINGS.
THE FBI.
>> Jesse: THE REVOLUTIONS CAME
THROUGH LIGHT THROUGH TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
THE TEXTS RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
JIM COMEY'S TESTIMONY TO
CONGRESS ABOUT THE CLINTON
BE CALLED AGAIN TO TESTIFY ABOUT
>> HE SAID NO DECISION WAS MADE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION UNTIL
AFTER JULY 2, 2016, INTERVIEW
WITH THE FBI.
THE PROBLEM IS, THESE TEXTS
INDICATE THAT PAGE AND STRZOK
AND LYNCH IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
MEMBER OF THE TEAM KNEW DAYS,
WEEKS, AND IN SOME CASES MONTHS
BEFORE THAT SHE WASN'T GOING TO
BE CHARGED.
THAT IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE
TESTIMONY HE GAVE UNDER OATH.
IF ALL THE FOLKS WORKING FOR THE
DIRECTOR KNEW THAT SHE WASN'T
GOING TO BE CHARGED, I THINK THE
DIRECTOR HAD TO KNOW.
MESSAGES BETWEEN STRZOK AND
PAGE.
THE FBI TELLS FOX NEWS "A FEW
THOUSAND CELL PHONES OF
IT PREVENTED MESSAGES TO BE
STORED OR UPLOADED TO THE
BUREAU'S ARCHIVE SYSTEM."
KIMBERLY, I WANT TO START WITH
THE FBI'S PRIMARY JOB IS I THINK
DATA COLLECTION AND EVIDENCE
COLLECTION.
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE BACKUP
LAYERS.
TRIPLE BACKUP, QUADRUPLE BACKUP.
THOSE PREVENT AGAINST
EARTHQUAKES AND 9/11 ATTACKS AND
THEY'VE GOT TO BE RECOVERABLE.
I THINK THEY MIGHT BE BUYING
PROSECUTED WERE PEOPLE HAVEN'T
TRIED TO DESTROY EVIDENCE.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHO TO GO TO.
THE FBI SHOULD BE ABLE TO PULL
IT TOGETHER.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF EVERY
INVESTIGATION THEY DID WAS
THWARTED BY PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE AND DELETE
EMAILS AND DO THINGS OF THIS
NATURE.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION,
LOOK HOW THAT WAS HANDLED.
THE BLEACH VICTIM THE
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE.
THIS IS VERY DISCONCERTING.
THE MAJORITY OF FBI AGENTS AND
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK THERE,
THEY ARE OUTSTANDING AND
COMMITTED AND DEDICATED AND
FANTASTIC.
WE REALLY OWE THEM SO MUCH
BECAUSE THEY MAKE HARDLY ANY
MONEY.
THEY WORK INCREDIBLY LONG HOURS
TO KEEP US SAFE DOMESTICALLY.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING LIKE
OUT BECAUSE YOU WANT A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL INVESTIGATION.
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT NOW IS
THAT, WHY ARE THESE MISSING?
I DO BELIEVE THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO RECOVER DELETED FILES.
TREMENDOUS TECHNOLOGY AND
FORENSIC RECOVERY TO    TO DO JS
OBVIOUSLY DON'T PEOPLE -- PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO GET CAUGHT.
THEY TRY TO DELETE AND REMOVE IT
THEY TRY TO DELETE AND REMOVE I
IT.
IF THE FBI CAN'T DO THIS AND
PULL IT TOGETHER, WE'VE GOT A
PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: BIG PROBLEM.
KIMBERLY BROUGHT UP THE
HILLARY CLINTON SITUATION.
>> Marie: YOU ARE LOOKING
RIGHT AT ME.
>> Jesse: YES, WE ARE
DIRECTING THIS AT YOU.
COMEY SAID HE NEVER DECIDED TO
CHARGE HILLARY CLINTON BEFORE HE
INTERVIEWED HER.
HE WAS GOING TO WAIT UNTIL AFTER
THE INTERVIEW.
LYNCH, THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CHIEF KNEW THAT THE FIX WAS IN
ON HILLARY BEFOREHAND.
SO IF COMEY COMES BACK, DO YOU
THINK COMEY IS IN TROUBLE?
>> Marie: I DON'T.
I THINK JIM COMEY TOOK A LOT OF
DOWN.
NOTHING WE'VE HEARD PROVES THAT
HE SAID ANYTHING INCORRECT IN
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN
THE EXONERATION?
THAT HE MAY HAVE LINTNER --
WRITTEN A LETTER THAT WASN'T
EXONERATING HER.
>> Jesse: MAYBE THEY MISPLACED
THAT LETTER.
>> Marie: MAYBE THERE'S A
REASON IT HASN'T BEEN LEAKED.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT?
>> Jesse: I HAVE NOT BUT
THANK YOU TO    TO FOR BRINGINGI
THANK YOU TO    TO FOR BRINGINGT
THANK YOU TO    TO FOR BRINGINGO
MY ATTENTION.
>> Marie: I AGREE THESE WERE
BUT I DON'T LIKE IS
EXTRAPOLATING FROM THESE TEXTS
WHICH WE DON'T KNOW THE WHOLE
STORY.
ENTIRE MUELLER INVESTIGATION NOT
PATRIOTIC FBI AGENT STILL
WORKING ON IT.
>> Jesse: OKAY, I SEE THE
POINT, BUT WHERE ARE THE TEXT
MESSAGES?
THAN I HAVE.
A WHITE COP, RACIST, DOESN'T
LIKE BLACK PEOPLE AND HE IS OUT
THERE PATROLLING AN ALL-BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE SAY THAT'S TROUBLING.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE BAD
APPLES, BAD COPS PATROLLING THAT
KIND OF BEAT.
INVESTIGATION.
DOESN'T THAT SHOW BIAS AND
SHOULD IN FACT KIND OF --
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
SAID IS THAT AS SOON AS MUELLER
TAKES OVER AND FINDS OUT ABOUT
THEM, HE FIRES THEM.
>> Jesse: WAS THE DAMAGE DONE?
THE FBI.
THEY ARE NOT FIRED.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
FORTHCOMING EITHER.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO DESTROY
THE REPUTATION OF THE FBI PIECE
BY PIECE SO WE CAN DEFEND
AGAINST THESE ALLEGATIONS OF
COLLUSION.
IN THE TEXT MESSAGES THAT DO
EXIST, PETER STRZOK SAYS YOU
KNOW THERE IS NO "THERE" THERE.
I DON'T LIKE THAT TEXT MESSAGE.
GOING TO PROSECUTE HILLARY OR
NOT RECOMMENDED.
AT THE TIME WE HAD MANY PEOPLE
IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
SUPPORTERS OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SAYING THEY HAD SOURCES WITHIN
MANY AGENTS WHO WERE FURIOUS AT
COMEY BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
STAND HILLARY CLINTON AND THEY
COULDN'T BELIEVE THE FACT --
NOW YOU HAVE ONE PARTISAN MEMO
VERSUS ANOTHER PARTISAN MEMO.
BOTH ARE LIKE "I MIGHT REVEAL
IT.
I MIGHT REVEAL IT."
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD REVEAL
THEM IF YOU WANT TO DO.
IT'S A MISTAKE TO GO DOWN THIS
THE FISA WARRANT, THE COMES
FORWARD, THAT PRODUCES THE
WIRETAP, GET THE INFORMATION.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THAT PERIOD, THEN YOU
HAVE A MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM ON
EVERYBODY TO JUST STOP RIGHT
NOW.
LET THEM ALL DO THEIR JOBS.
LET THE COMMITTEE TO THEIR JOB.
LET MUELLER DO THE JOB.
>> Kimberly: SHE IS TALKING TO
YOU, JESSE.
>> Dana: HOW MANY PEOPLE CAME
ON FOX NEWS AND SET ALL THESE
PEOPLE WITHIN THE FBI.
THEY ARE FURIOUS WITH JAMES
COMEY.
>> Brian: THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MANAGEMENT
AND FIELD OFFICERS.
FIELD OFFICERS DO THE HARD WORK
AND MANAGEMENT IS SEPARATE.
ONE THING IS CLEAR TO ME,
TALKING FBI AGENTS.
THEY ARE NOT MANAGEMENT BECAUSE
THEY ARE BETTER.
THEIR MANAGEMENT BECAUSE THEY
CHOSE THAT CAREER PATH.
GOING TO WASHINGTON, BE A
MANAGER, AS OPPOSED TO BEING A
FIELD AGENT.
DEPUTY.
ON JAMES COMEY, IF THE MEMO IS
CORRECT, COMEY HAS A PROBLEM.
HE SAID IN SEPTEMBER 2016 WHEN
ASKED IF YOU MAKE THE DECISION
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON BEFORE OR
AFTER SHE WAS INTERVIEWED?
INTERVIEW AND AWAY WE COULD
PROVE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
HAPPEN IN THE INTERVIEW.
HE'S ON THE RECORD SAYING HE
DIDN'T MAKE UP HIS MIND.
HE HAS TO COME UP WITH AN ANSWER
FOR THAT.
ON THE PROBLEM WITH SAMSUNG.
TALKING ABOUT SAMSUNG, WAS THERE
A PROBLEM WITH THE EQUIPMENT.
THEY SAY THEY BELIEVE SAMSUNG
DEVICES ARE NOT THE CAUSE OF
THIS ISSUE.
WE WILL FULLY COOPERATE WITH ANY
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN FOX NEWS LEARNS A FEW
THOUSAND FBI EMPLOYEES'
CELL PHONES WERE AFFECTED BY A
TECHNICAL GLITCH.
THEY SAY WE HAVE 3500 AGENTS,
10% WERE LOOKED AT AND THEY ARE
TAKING STEPS TO POSSIBLY RECOVER
THE TEXT MESSAGES.
THAT'S AN ISSUE.
I THINK THE FBI IS GROWN UP
ENOUGH AND SMART ENOUGH TO
WE ARE SAYING SOMETHING
QUESTIONABLE ABOUT ABOUT THESE
TWO IN PARTICULAR.
NOT TOO THRILLED WITH BRUCE OHR
AND HIS WIFE EITHER.
IF YOU ARE IN AN ORGANIZATION
RUNNING WELL AND FOUR OR FIVE
BAD APPLES DO BAD THINGS, IT
SHOULDN'T REFLECT ON US.
>> Dana: WE KNOW THAT WELL.
DEFINITELY TRUE.
>> Jesse: DANA MADE THE POINT
THAT STRZOK, WHEN HE WAS INVITED
TO JOIN THE MUELLER TEAM, SAID
HE DIDN'T SEE A LOT OF "THERE"
THERE WITH THE COLLUSION CASE
AND HE WAS RETICENT TO JOIN.
>> Dana: IT'S NOT GOING TO
>> Jesse: A SUBSEQUENT TEXT,
HE SAID SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
WANTING TO TAKE CARE OF
UNFINISHED BUSINESS BASED OFF
THE RESULT OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE CONTEXT FOR
THERE IS ANOTHER REASON FOR THEM
TO JOIN THE MUELLER TEAM.
DO YOU THINK THE MUELLER TEAM AT
THIS POINT IS COMPROMISED?
>> Kimberly: I THINK THERE IS
CERTAINLY AN AIR OF IMPROPRIETY
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT RELATES TO.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE EVIDENCE
YET.
AND I THINK ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS IS ALSO AWARE OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIND
OUT.
I MEAN, THERE IS ENOUGH THERE.
>> Jesse: ALLOWED TO GET
INVOLVED OR --
AND JEFF SESSIONS ABOUT HIS
DECISION TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
CASE REGARDING THESE TEXT
>> Kimberly: MAKING PUBLIC
STATEMENTS ABOUT IT.
>> Brian: I THINK MUELLER HAS
STOPS THEM FROM GOING FORWARD.
>> Dana: I THINK THE FACT THAT
HE FIRED STRZOK WORKS IN HIS
FAVOR.
WHETHER STRZOK, WHEN HE TALKED
TO FLYNN, WAS THAT
HAPPEN THERE INITIALLY WHICH LED
TO WHAT WE HAVE NOW WHICH IS THE
GUILTY PLEA?
>> Brian: TO SET THEM UP WITH
THE QUESTION HE KNEW HE WOULD
ANSWER.